[Music]
you ready Femina conquer Ninjago
I'll be waiting
dad all right
what was that last thing you said wait
that last part they didn't catch it
well I didn't say anything what do you
mean I didn't well I said I'll be
waiting and then I stopped talking dad
no Lloyd that's right your son and it's
Lloyd no ll o yd I named you you ruined
my life that's not true I haven't even
been a part of your life how could I
ruin it I wasn't even there baby now we
got bad
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm taking a solemn oath to form the
secret ninja force
are you ready to risk your life but
Ninjago yes I am maybe I know you want
me to save myself so I'll go now I
promise I'll never forget you I didn't
promise that
[Music]
hello who is this
Lloyd Garmadon your son must've
butt-dialed you
[Music]
it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect I mean my mom is weird
and collect seashells your dad levels
cities and attacks innocent people so
they've all got that quarks you know
[Music]
it's so on
[Music]
[Music]
hello fellow teenager hey hey man
my mom is on my case all the time she's
all and I'm like lay off mom I'm just a
teenager I hear that bro hey give me a
hard man give me up guys check out my
new paint job
the lady iron dragon my hero hey
everyone look it's garma dork and a dork
squad you want to hear our new cheer oh
oh oh I see his dad is bad and so is he
boo Loy boy oh boy
great chance I'll bet you got a
number-one hit on your hands I am
straight in at number one with a bullet
stand back put down the ultimate weapon
green ninja we both know you're not
gonna fire it is your last chance get
out of the jogo now and forever no what
have you done
[Music]
well generals congratulations
we finally conquered Ninjago I'm not
certain we did that I was being
sarcastic every time I try and conquer
Ninjago that meddling green ninja
thoughts me who are these super ninjas
every time I come up with a new plan
they still beat me and they don't even
have cool suits and you guys have like
crab outfits and shark outfits
I mean maybe we're spending too much on
outfits that sounds right to me sir oh
come on now look you guys gotta think
for yourselves I'm not your father
alright general number one you want to
be a follower then you want to be a
leader leader how dare you in tired of
you trying to conquer Ninjago alright
pretty ninja listen just calm down you
don't have to use that thing so you're
going to leave Ninjago yeah forever I
promise what are you why is your hand
behind your back what are you doing back
there are you crossing your fingers
that's physically impossible like how
could I be crossing my fingers I have
these things I'm more than you Garmadon
find no crosses no crosses just chill
okay look I'm getting rid of all my
sharks see oh sure the Sharks in your
ankle holster and don't have any shot
within your ankle sitting up with
dolphins manatees loca
hey get rid of them huh happiness I'm
done you win
ninja team shout out your cold side so
ninja all right take it away it says
water Matt ready and standing by
hey come on buddy ice max loading
loading loading loading ready Jay yeah
yeah I got the lightning back ready
wait so not ready ready cool you want to
get thrown out but earth neck turntable
dancer 3/3 rpms ready and standing by
three ninja ready and standing by
Oh ninjas hit it
all right ninjas follow me as long as
the empties max we're unstoppable here's
a thought what if I didn't go to school
today
what oh no you don't want to miss school
honey these are the best years of your
life
um have you have you been to high school
cuz it's judgy pretty judgy oh honey you
just need to give him a chance to see
the real you
yeah I don't think I can actually show
people the real me
that's not true all you've got to do is
to show them the person you are on the
inside right here where it matters most
oh and also don't forget if your dad
attacks the city again today just be
sure to Duck and Cover give the
all-clear oh and also don't forget ya
have a happy birthday honey thanks mom
you have the power to win the battle
without fighting when you start using
your mind you want me max and machines
your cosines are not just cool names
they are the elemental powers you were
all born with Nia you can create water
on your own and Koli these elemental
powers are why I choose you to form the
secret ninja force it is the highest
level that you can achieve as a ninja
and and and what about me what am I your
elemental power is green don't think
it's an element though Lloyd can I be
gold no wind isn't taken could I be wind
no earth green and fire rolls right off
the tongue Lloyd the element of surprise
no that's the fuchsia ninja surprise
Lloyd yeah that's your dad your open
hands it was all a point yet
for me it's easy to fight up disease
like not my father but for you that must
be so complicated not that complicated
you also really pulled at my
heartstrings yeah I found four years
with the mythos no the other stuff I
don't dad stuff yeah but like exactly
what are you referring to watching you
and your father the vulnerability you
got so emotional that emotion emotions
we're the last thing that was going on
out there
um yeah mm-hmm it's okay Lloyd
nobody's parents are perfect I mean my
mom is weird and collect seashells your
dad levels cities and attacks innocent
people so they've all got that quarks
you know
[Music]
oh brother where are your little ninja
ninja nerd where your little ninja nerds
nailed it
they're surrounding you perfectly hidden
ready to strike
oh really student next lesson how to
fight like a true ninja hey mom um could
we talk about dad
so when you guys got together was dad
always an evil warlord okay well here it
is I got you so many plans he was so
ambitious he said he wanted to conquer
the world I thought it was a figure of
speech but if I had never met Garmadon I
would have never had you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
students are to ninja nose and when to
fight and when to plant in the shadows
[Music]
unbelievable
the Lloyd that's right and it's void dad
baby now we got bad
[Applause]
[Music]
it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect yeah but I feel like there's
more to Garmadon that I need to know to
understand your future you must go back
to your ninja roots your dad was a ninja
too you know it you hear that we don't
wake up the unstoppable beast the Alpha
are you ready to risk your life for
Ninjago ninja
I haven't felt that good in a long time
good lord
are you okay yeah yeah I think I think
there's my arm is it bad I want to look
a scale of 1 to 10 to help that is it oh
I'd say it's about a seven-point arm
ripped off
[Music]
[Music]